[Music]
britney spears is officially the body
transformation can you believe this was
the 35 year old mom of two just two
years ago and here she is now
[Music]
so how did she do it well britney's a
fan of yoga crunches weights and running
but we won't bury the lead we don't
think it's a coincidence that her
boyfriend of nearly nine months 23 year
old sam ashgari is a hot model and
personal trainer can you say fitness
inspiration
[Music]
would you hold it against me
britt's hot body rules seem to be one
take it outside she posted this sweat
session in the backyard of our nine a
million dollar ellie estate
[Music]
two it's all about the abs britney does
planks crunches on a ball and doesn't
forget to focus on flexibility
[Music]
rule three reward yourself britt showed
off this new outfit during her vegas
show and she flaunts the results of her
hard work making her hallway her own
personal runway
the last rule give yourself a break we
love these posts feed me tacos and tell
me i'm pretty and my swimsuit told me to
go to the gym today but my sweatpants
were like nah girl you're good
god
[Music]